ursprünglich kamen die erkrankung
namenstages nur in zentral- und
südamerika vor doch jetzt warnen
behörden vor einer globalen ausbreitung
infiziert werden die betroffenen durch
raubwanzen und die krankheit ist echt
nicht ohne sie kann im schlimmsten fall
auch zum tod führen
der konkrete infektionsweg ist aber nur
was für hartgesottene es wird täglich
klicks um science fiction die gibt's
täglich faszinieren des seins videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr kein video herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
achtung jetzt wird es eklig denn die
wanzen krabbeln in die nähe der augen
und des mundes ihre opfer und beginnen
dort blut zu saugen in ihrem kot
befinden sich wiederum parasiten die
dann die infektion an sich hervorrufen
mittlerweile ist klar die chagas
krankheit ist längst keine
tropenkrankheit mehr die nur noch in
südamerika und mittelamerika auftritt
schätzungen zufolge sind in den
vereinigten staaten - 300.000 menschen
betroffen
und auch in kanada japan und australien
tritt die erkrankung immer häufiger auf
aber eben auch in europa nach
schätzungen der american heart
association gibt es weltweit
mittlerweile sechs millionen infizierte
andere quellen sprechen sogar von 18
millionen infizierten genau deswegen hat
die amerikanische non profit
organisationen gemeinsam mit der inter
american society of cardiology ein
statement herausgegeben in denen ärzte
teams weltweit dazu aufgerufen werden
sich über diese krankheit zu informieren
denn nur so kann sicherheit gestellt
werden dass die steigende gefahr erkannt
und kontrolliert wird konkret heißt es
in der erklärung
gesundheitsdienstleister und
gesundheitssysteme außerhalb
lateinamerikas müssten so ausgestattet
sein dass sie die stars krankheit
erkennen diagnostizieren und behandeln
und eine weitere krankheitsübertragung
verhindern können denn ja die gefahr der
chagas infektion ist nicht zu
unterschätzen dabei klingt der spitzname
der verantwortlichen insekten sogar ganz
niedlich kissing bugs also küssende
wanzen die raubwanzen sind selbst bis zu
vier zentimeter groß und dienen als
überträger der erreger selbst ist ein
einzeller die konkrete bezeichnung
lautet trieb arno so macht sie die
raubwanzen sind nachtaktiv und auf der
suche nach
mut von schlafenden säugetieren vögeln
reptilien oder eben auch menschen am
liebsten stechen sie dort wo die haut
besonders dünn ist also in der mund-
oder augenregion doch die infektion
erfolgt gar nicht durch den stich der
aufwand selbst sondern durch ihre
ausscheidungen die die erreger enthalten
gelangen diese in die frische stichwunde
in die augen oder schleimhaut der opfer
sind diese infiziert der code der wanzen
ist nach einschätzung von
forschungsteams sogar für jahre die
infektions bleibt die infektion
behandelt entwickeln etwa 30 prozent der
betroffenen erz und darminfektionen dies
kann im schlimmsten fall auch zu einer
chronischen form der erkrankung führen
samt herzversagen und der gefahr eines
plötzlichen todes in der frühen
infektions phase zeigen manche symptome
einer grippe wie gliederschmerzen und
fieber doch der großteil der betroffene
zeigt nicht einmal symptome so nennen
manche ärzte teams die erkrankung auch
leise mörder anhand einer
blutuntersuchung zeigt sich allerdings
schnell ob sich patienten und patienten
mit kras infiziert haben dann können
ärzte teams entsprechend medikamente
verabreichen in den usa sind bislang elf
raubwanzen bekannt die chagas übertragen
können vor allem in kalifornien texas
und florida tritt die krankheit auf
durch den weltweiten tourismus ist sie
mittlerweile fast in allen ländern
dieser welt vertreten
schon vor vier jahren 2014 hatten
ärzteteams alarm geschlagen denn schon
damals wurde eine hohe rate an chargers
infizierten festgestellt ebenso auch
eine hohe anzahl an herzerkrankungen die
mit dieser krankheit in zusammenhang
stehen das problem hat laut der ärzte
teams zwei dimensionen zum einen die
rasante ausbreitung von gas und zum
anderen das fehlende bewusstsein sowohl
diagnose als auch behandlungsmethoden
seien dringend zu überdenken zudem ist
laut der aktuellen erklärung auch
dringend die entwicklung neuer
medikamente notwendig diese sollten zum
einen weniger nebenwirkungen haben und
zudem auch während der schwangerschaft
eingenommen werden können dies ist
bislang nämlich nicht möglich nur so
könnte verhindert werden dass die zahl
der infizierten weiter in die höhe
steigt wir halten euch hier dazu auf dem
laufenden wenn er kein video dazu und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollen
abonniert klicks um auch auf englisch
denn auch da gibt es immer wieder video
premiere dafür einfach hier draufklicken
und da drunter geht es weiter mit camps
sowie trick des hennefer bis bald
hoffentlich auf dem englischen kanal zu
tun
stay tuned